astronomers now know that there are
billions of exoplanets in our galaxy
waiting to be discovered
but knowing they're there and finding
them are very different things the
problem with finding exoplanets is that
a plant is so tiny and so dim compared
to a star that it's essentially
undetectable unless you get very clever
one of the things you can do is you can
actually see that there's a
gravitational pull between a star and a
planet as amazing as it sounds as a
planet orbits a star
it'll tug on it gravitationally and the
star will wobble a little bit and you
can detect that
some of the first exoplanets were
discovered by looking for wobbling stars
but now there's a more effective way to
find these distant worlds perhaps more a
direct way of seeing exoplanets is by
the transit method in this case the
planet and the star lineup right exactly
in our view so that the planet goes
across the star making a tiny little
solar eclipse so we actually just find
that the star darkens in a pattern every
time this planet goes round
astronomers have used these methods to
find thousands of exoplanets
[Music]